hello the nice people at Google who own  YouTube suggested I make a trailer video  to encourage you to subscribe to my  youtube channel this is that trail this  is our tinder man very inviting I like  everybody I love watching videos on  YouTube let's all take a look how dare  you I'm trying to conduct an  investigation here if you are watching  at home and following us on Twitter you  should probably get your own apartment  eventually no you don't like this show  do you have enough parking here on Wall  Street now what's your cause besides  wanting more Eminem's and trail mix  women sent you these correct the very  definition of having this is proof that  you don't know I brought a  missile-firing Chopra back to the strip  club  you can check out my youtube channel at  youtube.com slash team  so subscribe now